[Music]
hey it's Jessie I'm here at the Wolfram
tech conference for those who are just
tuning in
I'm just here talking with developers
and other interesting people using
technology in really cool ways I'm here
what's a cheetah right now can you tell
us a little bit about sort of what you
do at Wolfram and also what you are
doing here at the conference this year
so just a week back I moved to the
advanced research group so in the
machine learning team so I work as a
research scientist trying to implement
and get import models for the composite
Ori and also to build applications for
various high-level functions and the
Wolfram language so that's what I do and
in the conference I so I already gave a
talk which was just about what I have
added in the neural network repository
and how to use that to make her
real-world applications on how you
customize them to make applications of
your choice and then I would be giving
another talk later which is kind of one
of my favorite projects where I talk
about like it's more for the social and
how you can use neural networks for
cancer diagnosis so that's what I am
doing in the conference so what so just
for our audience like what is the neural
net repository we've talked with Mateo
earlier and he told us sort of the new
things and the framework but we didn't
talk too much about the repository okay
so so the way from you know the
repository that just shot in it to
repository for now so they're the neural
net repository
it was launched a few months back and it
has almost around 80 models or so which
you can use for various applications so
it goes from image classification object
detection then you have semantic
segmentation I guess I can I could
whether it's me each of those terms
because somebody who's not familiar with
all of these tasks Greek so otherwise
there are various image processing
neural networks so essentially it's a
library of pre-trained models so one
feature or one thing which I should
mention is that all of those models
there are not trained some of them are
trained in the networking research but
many of them we have taken models that
have been implemented by like well
renowned researchers and we caught them
the weights have been verified and
tested so we go through a lot of steps
processes before we actually publish a
model in the future nice so they're like
just highly curated and so for example
so there was a blog post with sebastian
and material and Megan Italian what
about the repository so if you like if
you refer to it you see like the
ultimate the what should I say the the
results which you get from the the
repository by getting for asking the net
to do something for you it's in most of
the times it's in owns the entity so
it's like a rich computable data format
which you can just go and query and use
for your own application so it's it's
easy to use very well trained neural
nets which you can just use for your own
applications that's awesome so speaking
of applications what are some of the
like coolest application or the funnest
applications that you've seen of or have
done no cool firm neural networks ok so
so for me I am yeah I am more
application driven rather than
engineering driven so for most of the
people were most of the ones which I
like for some some social education and
then and then so let's let's start
talking about like one of them yeah
sorry I just plugged in this hdmi cord
[Music]
too much okay so let's go to the first
fan song here this so more of these will
come in the dark later but I'm just
showing showing our sneak peek of the in
here so it's so this one was for cancer
cell detection this was when we started
building this application for a client
so at that point in time I was working
for the Services team that's a
consulting tools within the company so
at a point we didn't have any
segmentation network in the repository
so we had to build this from scratch so
my point of showing this was how much
time it takes to build network from
scratch
train it see check accuracy that that's
more time consuming and I'll take them
Network from the repository so just cut
the head and the tail off and then put
in your own layers and make application
so but this one was trained from scratch
so this one is segment so semantic
segmentation was a model that was
published in 2015 so these are
essentially the layers that I had to put
up put in together so each of the model
consists of our encoder section so this
is inspired from vgg 16 of HD 19 just
has some batch normalization added to it
that so yeah these are all layers that
you get in the neural network framework
in the Wolfram language so so this is
essentially the encoder section of it
and then the decoder section and then
you put them both together stitch them
up again joining layers of these to make
your own application is very easy it's
just from that
and then you just change them up or if
you have a graphical structure using
that graph and then put the jeans to
make a graphical structure of the layers
so no net chain and net Grapher
functions and their first are their
arguments one two three are basically
the layers you can give them as a list
or you can give them as associations
associations associative arrays and
they're just to name the layer so that
you can get them so these are all the
arguments which you put to change the
layers together so and for yeah and for
graphs you do need to give the
connections like in any graph
you need to give the connections make
sense like one to two to the four yeah
so yeah so this is how you would
essentially train from scratch so the
first application I wanted to highlight
is how your network will scratch and
train it so here let's go to the results
they look more interesting oh yes so
this is so in the talk I will go in more
details about what each of the
applications are but here we are just
seeing some agency stained images so
they are this colorectal images which I
got so there are from publicly available
datasets so this one shows just benign
Tipu's
and you can see that so the original
image looked something like this and so
this is again a part of the image here
I'm just parting them and then I'm just
showing the last as all the images
stitch together but as you can see these
red outlines you see here is what the
network actually detected the boundaries
of the images are and the blue ones are
from the ground truth of the masks
I got from the dataset so it performed
really well so if I if I think it had
around 94% pixel wise accuracy and this
was a picture
segmentation Network which was built for
this purpose so yeah this one was more
of like I wanted this form like a
broader implication of how you can use
neural nets for so this is the one you
this is the one that when you were in
tech services you built from scratch and
yes so this is so we didn't actually use
it because this one's more public I say
this is a public dataset so and here is
one which which is from summer school
actually so he wanted to make something
for solar to calculate solar energy like
how much solar energy we can get if you
just had panels on top of moon stops of
just buildings like buildings you have
in the city so that's exactly so we have
used something similar so this is also a
semantic segmentation network but
instead of training from scratch we are
just using the repository to make this
model so you see that the lines of code
have gone down tremendously yeah so you
just take the model just getting the
model is just a single line of code take
the model just break it up so here we
are dropping the last two layers so and
then add your own layers for your custom
application and then stitch it all
together did you are the same and then
training part is slightly modified than
what you would have trained but not much
modification and then you get so there's
a tracer
does it train the whole network or like
retrain the network or doesn't only
train
so essentially of you really don't want
to retrain the entire network the main
reason why you want don't want to do
that is because training all the layers
requires a huge amount of data and for
most of your applications you don't
really have millions of images for
getting that level of accuracy so what
you do is to freeze the first few layers
the first layers and get the waves from
the free train model and let the last
few layers burn so it could be your
layers in some part of the architecture
so if I had to show it here so what this
application had was we so we let it
learn from six a to the end and kept the
above layers fixed and you do that using
learning rate multipliers which is again
a function M so that's essentially how
you do network surgery and use transfer
learning so you are essentially
transferring the learnt widths from the
first few layers and using it for your
application so that's that's how you
would do it as so that's that's the
repository where flavors
yes the first one was a scratch one the
main reason I wanted to show is because
you have the repository life is simply
to make your own a thinking oh yeah and
I'm all about I mean especially because
I'm not like in their own day I would
want to grab something like minimal and
just as a fun fact most of the students
here who came to the summer school did
not really have a background in neural
networks or AI or machine learning they
had some experience with the Wolfram
language but they built all of it
in a week so so if you happen to know
more machine learning or Wolfram
language I I think you can just print it
in a day or two just train it the GPU
training time does not really not like
it will take a day or so but then that's
how long it would take
[Music]
so yeah so let's go ahead I am just
showing so I'm just getting the
pre-trained Network here so here what I
am doing is just grabbing using again
geo image so this is a I should say that
cool thing about our framework is that
you have different functions built in
for different things so I could just get
it your image using the Geo image
function and if I had to do the same in
some other frameworks I would have had
to reload different libraries like if
I'm working with the machine learning or
the tensorflow library or any neural
network library I need different other
libraries to get things like this also
you can pass images as a solid input in
the neural net I don't think that's the
same for other yeah I converted to
matrix bombs yes so we do have net and
thank you for pointing me out to that so
here you see I hope so here you see all
I am doing is saying that I am tweeting
it an image and I am feeding is the
image of this size and this is the mean
of the image so there are many are times
where you where you would see that in
accuracy increases if you subtract the
mean and the variance of the image and
that's a normalization process so you
need to normalize your images so
essentially net encoder for images are
so well built that you just that you
just give this is the mean of the image
this is the variance of the image this
is the size and feeding and it will take
the image and reprocess it make it ready
for the framework this is the test image
I just looked up the geographical is the
latitude and longitude of
champaign-urbana so that's the latitude
of champaign-urbana let me go ahead get
the mosque it's very it's not iya so
again let me since super neural networks
if it's okay I mean I just real quick I
think we don't have enough time to go
through this okay but what just real
quick what's the like funnest okay so
yeah so this is something which have
been just for fun I was video chatting
in him neck yeah these snapchat filters
are very easy
eat don't wait you just have to find the
faces and there are okay I did not
initialize I know that for fun so let's
go back do it so here we have fine
facial features function so if you find
all the features in your face so it
finds essentially I saw which number
corresponding to the righty or the right
the right and the left ears and the nose
and just put the bunny so that's a
really funny Christmas card yes
community yeah yeah this is how I just
made it for multiple phases but that's
when I realized that you cannot do these
things for mobile handheld devices
because these networks are huge and
that's also some complain that we get
from customers that these are big
networks so right now which will be
coming in twelve that's another project
that I was doing is to is to find
network so we have the recently
published again mobile net from
tensorflow so we we planned we have
imported them in our framework and that
would be published as parametrized net
models because we have so many of them
and you can choose which version you
need for what sort of application and
hearing mobile in yeah so you can
actually run them because they are
smaller network that's that's what I was
trying to show here so the resonate
which has similar accuracy to the top
most earth
the best-performing network has around
60 million parameters well this has six
million parameters right so it's like a
factor of 10 less and which means that
this will be much smaller it is a factor
of 10 smaller and you can use them for
your mobile devices these were trained
to do that so hopefully that will
support mobile neural networks in
version 12 they will support smaller
networks and then again the image
processing team is busy taking these
networks and putting them in image
identify an audio identify so that you
can have like a smaller network for each
of these functions so yes we will have
smaller networks oh well thanks for
talking with me this year appreciate it
thank you for inviting me awesome
so stick around I'll be interviewing
more developers little later on